over the past year many families were
simultaneously dealing with loss of
income
and unexpected financial costs due to
covet 19.
to help ease that burden fema is
offering its funeral assistance program
to families who lost loved ones due to
the virus
reporter kate houston joins us live in
the newsroom tonight with how this will
impact families all across southern
nevada
kate yes sasha while this money will not
be able to replace the loss of a loved
one local funeral homes hope
it will bring these families some
closure and help them move forward
starting tomorrow funeral assistance
applications will open
which will provide up to nine thousand
dollars in financial assistance
i spoke to a few local families who say
this takes a
big weight off of their shoulders she
loved to live
love to and live to laugh and that's the
best thing i can say about my mother
patrick casau lost his 84 year old
mother marlene to covet 19 last december
for many families these hospital and
funeral costs were unexpected and made a
difficult situation
even harder to get somebody cremated is
not inexpensive it's not like it's 500
bucks
we're talking like you know four grand
all in and then you have to pay for
death certificates and everything else
after sandra smith's cousin catherine
died of covid 19 in march of last year
the family had to pay out of pocket for
the funeral
it's almost impossible to bury someone
if you don't have one life insurance or
a stack of money
you know hidden under your mattress or
anything both families will be applying
for fema's funeral assistance program to
qualify the death certificate must state
they passed from covid 19
and that expenses started after january
20
of 2020. the contract and receipts for
the funeral arrangements must also be
provided heritage mortuary in las vegas
says this money will help many families
pay off credit cards
or loans that were used for services and
can help fulfill their loved one's final
wishes
they men have not had enough to actually
put them away in the cemetery after the
cremation
with this application and applying for
the nine thousand dollars they may be
able to get
extra funds to go ahead and get a niche
for their loved one
both casal and smith say this will help
many families who have struggled to give
their loved one a proper goodbye
there's a lot of anger and a lot of
there's a lot of questions that have
gone
unanswered and so i would sit there and
say this is they're trying i think
they're trying to help people get some
closure
fema says they have received reports
that scammers are reaching out to people
offering to register them for this
assistance fema has not sent
out these notifications and they will
not directly contact you for this
program back to you sasha